Welcome to The Super Family's eleventh movie, The Universal War. You will experience pure action, built from the finest, finest, finest, and when I say finest, I mean finest, development.
Now, for a few rules on our greatest movie ever, here is Amanda Young.
I'm not going to go over the whole lecture of cellphones, I'm just going to say no cellphones, but you can do that like typing words in for it, but it can't make any sounds, no pointing, hitting, screaming, or...
Of course no screaming.
Poking. I mean poking on the screen, like kicking the screen, punching the screen.
Like this.
On your way in.
But I'm just going over there and kicking.
No smoking, of course. We don't want people with those little, um, those little stick things.
Oh, I'm cold.
Nah, this stuff will kill you.
That was the first thing I said.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, um, okay, I went over that.
No kicking!
Okay.
At least, um, well, well, the guy said that, right?
Start this movie. It is the greatest ever.
Greatest yet.
This movie's still a candidate.
Okay. Now, the eighth, like, universal war!
Okay, um, I'll just say you tomorrow at school. Bye!
Because I was just on the phone.
I'm going to try and get us some food.
Oh, Stacy, give me that.
Yeah, what is it?
What?
An attack?
On Gamblia? On Gamblia?
Yeah, yeah, we'll be right there after we get to the house, okay?
We just got on the road.
Get out the window.
Take a shot right here.
Fish and cream.
Oh, Stacy, I forgot to tell you.
Mm-hmm?
There's been an attack on Gamblia.
We're going to have to start the war now.
Do you think I should go call the troops?
Don't let the kids know about this until it's actually going on right now.
Okay.
I'm going to have to go rally the troops. I'll be right back.
We're going to have to rally them.
Stacy!
Stacy, you're still trying to pick out a necklace!
I'm not going to wear a necklace or two scarves.
Or a flashy scarf.
Well, that's not for me to decide.
You teenagers know what to wear during a war?
Hmm.
What kind of fashion statement is going to be going on while the war is over?
Maybe just like normal war.
Like the Army? Like those clothes that wear the cocktail collage?
I don't know.
Are you trying to get into uniform to get in front of the troops?
troops so they were making that will make you like important yeah and we should have at least stayed
at the hideout so i could do my hair is that what you care about instead of getting universal
power conquering the world you care about what you look like is everybody gonna care
they might just say oh evil sister you look so nice and then you put her in the face
when my slave troop when my slave troops move out then our real plan will begin we shall sneak
into the ac shield generator and shut it down and then we will destroy the ac that mask is getting
old it's the mask of darkness
you
it doesn't have much work on it i'll work on it for the next movie no those fools will never see
it coming and besides my robot is ready aha don't interfere with this are you ready to address the
slave troops yes nothing can stop me with this mask with this mask i will make anything that
i look at evil the only thing that counts is dare you only master
you can conquer this one it's thevem the mask of what but this is like nobody's gonna get that like
the super family's already full with members how could they get the toe the toe of light don't smell
we should throw your mom in the laundry and shoot again now we will go address the troops
i mean our slaves evil sister time to go address the army this is dr senor
addressed to you today that we face a horrible evil. We must destroy it. All 25 billion of you
should make it through. We must destroy this evil. He has been menacing us for many years
and it is time we destroy him once forever. Troops, commander, what is your, scout commander,
what is your report? Scout commander, what is your report? Yes, sir. We have, um, yes, sir.
We have located that Makuta is ready to advance and also my troops are ready to advance on your
command. We shall show no mercy to the enemy. And you shall do that. Sorry, I was just getting a
drink. Um, and you will do that. You are at my command, so you have the order to go.
Well, when I am ready. If you have any last minute questions, please tell me now. It doesn't look like
I'm going to have any, so. Commanders, Bohrok, Firmata Nui, ships, troop carriers, you have
five troops. It's between good and evil. Evil will prevail. I must tell you now that your target is
not those, those stupid bastards. Those battle droids can regenerate themselves.
There is no point wasting your energy. Our target are the innocent people living in the AC.
Now, show no mercy. No matter what. If there are children, who cares? If there are, if there are
women, who cares? If there are men, have them. Even Pokemon, too. Even pets. All of them must die.
Single one. Questions? Yes, our, do, can we retreat?
No, you can not. Uh, uh, okay. Um, okay.
Yes, me.
Machine, Captain Rahi, the order.
Looks pretty bad out there.
Hmm.
You know, you know, Cole has the ability to make it storm.
How come we don't hear any thunder?
I don't know. I think it's supposed to get bad pretty late, later.
I saw some lightning over there.
Huh.
Um.
This looks really bad.
Yeah. I heard some thunder before.
Whoa, did you see that? It just got darker.
Oh.
Now, that's weird.
That is breaking.
I mean, there.
Ooh, down here.
Doesn't look very good.
Let's go inside.
Let's just take one more look around here. I'm just surprised how bad it looks. I mean,
maybe it's a sign of the war.
How bad it is out here.
I mean, it used to be so happy and peaceful about two minutes ago, and as soon as I called
the troops, everything just started pouring like this.
Even though I read the dead troops have dropped their leaves.